you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 3-2
game
so let's gun for any Slav here support
the d5 pawn let's go with this a six
line I could have also considered Bishop
out okay so I don't have to worry about
Queen b3 yeah let's go to a more
aggressive post I think this is a good
spot
okay just back up I thought maybe g4
mmm-hmm let's play c6 maybe I'll go to
c6 something with c5 and knight c6
scratch that let's immediately guard a
five okay I'm happy so far with my
position I could take and play Knight
here huh mmm I could even take and then
play Bishop check hmm I'm gonna take and
play Knight e4 immediately with h3 it's
difficult to kick this knight now
because I have Knight g3 he needs to be
challenged but he can't be challenged
right away probably Castle and I'm gonna
play this first provoke maybe some
weakness on a3 and then at some point
maybe I'll have to tend to this pressure
pretty even position they're playing
with the space advantage slight don't
know how big a deal it'll be I think I
could take and then actually take again
and c4
Oh slow down just a hair here
simplifying quite a bit huh
let's take here okay so I have our
healthy majority on the queenside also
playing with the better Bishop hmm king
or rook I have some time to consider
here I think my king will do well to sit
on c7 I want one
rooks off the board I want this to be a
bit bit more technical let's see let's
go with the King pulling here and then
play the rook here okay
Bishop deform hmm they happy to see that
move change one rook and then contest
the open file yeah I think that this is
I think that this is good take with the
King or bishop not sure it matters too
much take with the king I want to keep
control over this square so there's no
clamping down type of thing so how to
win this definitely the better side here
okay I think a start is v5 yeah let's
get V 5 in and take like this okay just
get my king up now function on the light
squares hmm
alright let's continue to approach I
think that this is a key move actually I
want to work my King around to a4 I
think this is an important move now
they're not allowing me or they're not
preventing me from getting my King up
here hmm
I have no fear of them creating a passed
pawn over here I just played g6 and I
never capture when this pawn is on f5 so
let's sneak around you know just king up
let me double check
yeah I still don't have I don't have any
fear and they're just let me improve my
king position with that much of an issue
let's just go here all pawns on light
squares
maybe this oh this was actually better
okay I could still get that in because
now I have pressure on this pawn they
have to defend it with the bishop hmm
okay I definitely take with the off bone
we don't want this guy getting past so
now they have to defend here and what's
the cleanest win push here
yeah probably get him rolling and King
here and then I could push a couple more
times this is uh they should be pretty
clean from here hmm I think I was okay
now it's definitely win because a king
here they gave up a king position no he
can't even be stopped
yeah they resigned I think the issue
just before I even look at it what the
computer was Knight to e5 hmm allowing
uh allowing the capture you know playing
with this double D pawns and the copy it
got way too simplified let me just go
into it real quick here so there's
position right around here and I think
that this was too quick
this um space advantage that White has I
don't know how no I don't know it that
you could really put it to great use if
there are more pieces on the board and
it might be difficult to work around but
I only have two minor pieces I'll be
able to find out if it's adequate
squares for my minor pieces and I think
that that that move was maybe just too
fast
night into e5 or maybe it shouldn't be
played at all maybe maybe the other idea
is I don't know knight Knight to c3 and
then look for an e4 break or maybe even
at this point if you say the h3 move
after h3 Bishop back maybe go straight
in for g4 and then try and look for this
type of imbalanced knife for Bishop
exchange had this been played I would
follow up with Knight on f2 d7
challenging the night like this runs
into h4 and it's a very awkward now
although although not not quite the case
here because I have this as a
possibility to get out of the bishop the
bishop quite possibly being pinned or a
trapped I should say after h5 so with a
knight still on b1 I don't know how how
great an idea this is actually in a
different situation if I'm to just
insert one more move for each side let's
just say after Bishop here the knight
played I don't know let's say here and
I'm just going to make a dummy move just
a passing move to illustrate if the
knight is on this square already
developed this idea of h3g for Bishop
pack 95 I think it's best well I have
some concern on d5 here but if I am to
challenge the night like this with the
Queen Knight then there is this move h4
and now it's quite awkward I never want
to play h6 because I lose the light
square Bishop and I'm having to take
away from the center and there's serious
light square weaknesses if I'm able to
take like this it's a much different
story taking towards the center Brooke
is brought to life and g6 and a 6 are
not gaps they're not holes so this this
would be an issue now actually for me
with h4 takes here my knight is hit and
when he moves here comes h5 and my
bishop short on squares he's going to be
trapped
so anyhow it was still an idea the two
in the game after age three to play I
think g4 and then at least follow up
here and track down my light square
bishop and then play this one out but
you know I kind of had it a little bit
easy with I I felt very comfortable I
should say as soon as I was able to
deploy my light square bishop this was
maybe a bit too soon to play b3 normally
from my experience b3 will be played
only when some pressure is exerted on c4
what when b3 was played one of my first
thoughts I don't know that I was able to
express it
we were playing a pretty quick right out
of the right out of the opening there
but when b3 is played and you know I
don't have any concern of course about
the Queen coming out to this B 3 square
putting pressure on b7 so I can much
more freely deploy my light square
bishop without this mm-hmm
fairly common reply to to then target
the weak point that I leave behind when
I do deployed the bishop so b3 rules out
to any Queen side influence the white
queen might have in my position so yeah
I don't know what else there is to say
really
before I ask in this over with a
computer pretty natural developing moves
just got too simplified you know maybe
maybe this is an adjustment as well
definitely need to keep the Queen's on
the board I think playing here allows
the the exact move sequence we had in
the game where if we're going into this
ending I can only see it as black being
better a3 perfectly healthy group of
three versus two on the Queen side and
um its material balance but it feels
like I'm just up upon here because these
guys cannot
successfully create a passed pawn on
their own so maybe better didn't mean to
go all the way back but maybe better
here as a last as a little bit of an
adjustment maybe instead of 92 it's
better to challenge the night like this
that way on a capture here the Queen's
are still going to be on the board and
then maybe even queen g4
I don't know queen g4 with f4 f5 looking
for some attack but if it becomes much
more technical an endgame without the
Queen's on the board this advantage here
and the Queen side is a more easily
realize let's just say but anyhow let's
quickly skim it over with a stock fish
and see what more we can take away from
this one okay let's see what we could
take away from this one have a Slav on
board with this a six move this is
eventually aimed at trying to resolve
this tension in the center between the C
and D pawns with this beef b5 move but
again as mentioned more it's more common
to see b3 only after white has actually
followed through with the b5 move only
once questioned on c4 will we normally
see b3 so just a little move order a
detail b3 of course is not bad but this
allows me to get my light square Bishop
out freely prior to e6 so I really don't
have any opening issues any any problems
to really solve so likes Bishop to e2
this is where I was pointing out maybe
going for this is this in fact an idea
sure you know I could play a six here
yeah it's it's an idea to still go in
this direction minor piece imbalance
just another position white maintains a
solid structure White has the bishop
pair
it's just another way to play it Bishop
e2 in the game it should be for a check
mm-hmm okay
one night there right away it does not
like this instead castles okay hmm okay
suppose castles and I don't know that I
would want to play here because I want
to be able to take this night when it
plays to e5 I want to be able to take it
with my knight you know this isn't
possibility anymore because I would end
up in a fork so I think if white is to
Castle instead of Knight to e5 in the
game I would play Bishop to e7 excuse me
after if they were to castle here I
would probably follow up with Bishop e7
I say Knight c3 Castle some pretty
natural moves to c1 and now it's calling
out for Bishop to b4 mm-hmm okay
yeah I guess I could now that the if the
knight is playing to c3 I could even
think about Bishop to d6 you know there
isn't this Knight e5 idea anymore
although there might still be this 95
idea because on Bishop takes Bishop
there's Knight takes and then the bishop
is there to see the knight indirectly
yeah it's a pretty slow position
nobody's going to get killed right away
it's just finding useful squares for
pieces developing still of course yeah
so they went with 95 it's where it
shifts a little bit it likes inserting a
check nothing wrong with capturing
either Knight takes pawn takes and now
Bishop check huh now in 94 what's the
story with here I thought that just
Bishop blocks takes Knight takes okay if
we do have a dark
Bishop exchange they have some concern
over F for and on no concern over a five
they have to play f4 and then there's
maybe even a check and that likes
castles and then maybe the idea is f6
calls for Queen e7 but I think f6 is a
move as well it is okay as it played out
and this one after the Knights were
exchanged you know it likes Knight to c3
yeah night to d2 this is a becoming too
simplified with the Queen's coming off
doesn't like King takes it does like
King takes probably the same evaluation
with rook takes yeah
maybe being a bit too I don't know
trying to be a bit too perfect on this
move here but had some time I figured
that this was the best residence for my
King on c7 I definitely didn't want to
Castle kingside
because this is where the action is
going to occur on the Queen side so took
with the King how could I have done
better in this ending mm-hmm yeah I was
already mentioned right around this
point that I thought I just want to get
one pair of rooks off the board at least
as it turned out they were quickly both
exchanged and yeah it's that much more
easily realize this advantage here on
the Queen side three a healthy three
versus two versus an mmm an unhealthy
four versus purchasing me an unhealthy
five four white versus a four on the
Kings side
yeah cost rate Bishop to c3 mm-hmm okay
Bishop c3 with maybe this is the idea to
have ideas of Bishop to a5 hmm just had
the rooks contesting the open file one
pair of Brooks's off I know there is off
it's only showing as about a half pound
advantage
hmm King c7 I just played b5 right away
getting the Kings rolling I guess this
is still hold a bowl for white how could
they have held this better it's starting
to grow now sometime it's it's not
really a fan of that move hmm
it's quite natural to two to want to
play to position your pawns on light
squares so that they don't become
targets I don't really see what is wrong
with E for hmm I don't know if I will be
able to figure that one out
it makes a lot of sense I mean it takes
away this square it's it's it works well
it coordinates well with the bishop want
your pawns on light Bishop will be
around to guard the dark ok e4 still not
anything serious a right around this
point I thought the bishop needed to
play here just to stop my king from
getting over on this side of the board
real quick oh but that's not working huh
because I have Bishop c5 and if the if
it's just a King and pawn ending this is
completely winning and well if you avoid
the bishop exchange I'm winning the pawn
enough so you probably have to do this
before they even think about this move
so I was wrong to think that this was a
good idea it would not be because of my
reply Bishop c5 so they played f4 I
worked my king around and yeah I had no
fear of these the biggest thing here
when it comes time to assess the the the
Queen of the King side of the board is
you just never take on that five you
never you never capture here in this
position - under the pawns you just
leave them sitting you just maintain
this type of structure and wait for
white to capture you and there's no way
for white to trade
they passed pawn on the kingside
something did change here I maybe went
just a little bit too fast right around
this point King c2 is necessary although
maybe it's still already now giving it
some time here it is close to a pond and
a half advantage so it's looking pretty
serious may already be losing hmm yeah
it may may already be losing here Bishop
to d4 it just it just feels like if I
could get my king over here like this
that ya good you know good luck trying
to defend this it's quite tricky just a
really good King position and we're just
playing really on one side of the board
and have this extra pawn you know I
don't think that there was anything
wrong with how I played it g6 yeah it's
still holding an advantage I think that
this is just winning no matter what and
I just kept pushing my pond and as soon
as the king gave ground it just paved
the way for this move but I guess it was
still lost no matter what and what does
why do they have to watch over this pawn
or even if they gave it up let's just
say I don't know the bishop goes here I
could just move my king and then push
away you know I mean I'm already
threatening to push I don't have to
let's say defend my bishop I could just
start pushing like this in Queen so the
winning idea from this point would be
instead of King here king c2 and my
phone resigned at this point but if they
didn't play King here and let's say
Bishop I don't know here King a2 and on
King c4 okay King b1
King bee one and then came to see - yeah
this is just an enormous position right
here for the king you know there's not
really anything that I could do so
Bishop here King here if King c2 could
take the pawn and I'm just pushing
through next they end up having to give
their Bishop to have to suggest anything
really here
yeah and just pushing through okay yeah
the the main points here just a
different option of course for white
around this point to hunt down the
LightSquared Bishop this is another way
to play it going right in for the bishop
pair and Knight to e5 as it turns out
was just a bit too soon more development
was needed first castles Knight c3
Brooke c1 only maybe a little bit later
considering this Knight to e5 move and
really the last point was how exactly to
challenge the knight on e4 the Queen's
need to be maintained on this in this
position otherwise it's you know a very
difficult road ahead for team white
because as mentioned it's a healthy
three versus two majority on the Queen
side I'm basically playing up a pond in
this position so anyhow as usual feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below to this video and
as usual I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now take care bye